That's all fortune
, 10 doors The
time limit is
4 days for publication
If you exceed it, you'll be forced to quit oh
oh oh oh
Applejack ar
2000 mah
ani
uh
Did you get something that can use your brain a little
?  There's a clock in room 3. It's
time.
You can check it even in your pocket.
There's no
such a terrible betrayal
Maria I heard
rumors about bald-sama and Maria-sama saying they were lovers Ah, it's impossible
Parker concentration center mistake We believe that the
time limit is 10 minutes
Of course I want you to resist along the way, don't
trust anyone, don't believe in the distance that's deceiving you, keep your ears down.
Melah believe
me My rookie beauty Shona 4
ana
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow Curie
Why didn't you open that door?
It's to open the door within the time limit, so no matter which door you open, it's the correct answer.